I'm sorry, but that Sebastian
is actually a sheep outside, and it's really different,
but it feels like a small one, so I called it that and it's consistent
.  Ai Itadakimasu Miss
Katarina How are you feeling?
No, it's totally fine
[music]
ana,
Katarina-sama, you deliberately pretended to be fine with what you said.
Even when he
talks, he might look like a teacher's daughter.
If I do, I'll
just get hurt or scolded by a card
Hey,
that other person isn't
pushing himself too hard Everything is really delicious and
I want more refills Oh, I'm amazed.  No, Mr.
Serena, for what purpose did you bring me here?
Actually,
Lady Serena,
it's time to go back to your room. Katarina-sama must be tired, so please go to bed early
.